el administrador de una preparatoria
realizó una encuesta a una muestra
aleatoria de 100 alumnos de último año
para conocer su opinión sobre la comida
que se ofrece en la cafetería de la
escuela así que tenemos a todos los
estudiantes de último año suponiendo que
hay más de 100 de ellos y tenemos una
muestra de 100 de ellos tenemos esta
población que son todos los estudiantes
de último año de preparatoria de esta
escuela y la muestra es de 100 de ellos
así que los 100 estudiantes que
entrevistaron son nuestra muestra nos
preguntan identifica la población y la
muestra en este ejemplo veamos cuál de
estas opciones coincide con lo que
establecimos aquí y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta
la primera opción nos dice que la
población son todos los estudiantes de
último año de preparatoria en el mundo
la muestra son los alumnos de último año
de esta preparatoria en particular no
esto no es correcto no tratamos de saber
qué es lo que opinan sobre la comida de
la cafetería todos los estudiantes de
último año
historia en el mundo solo nos interesa
conocer la opinión de los estudiantes de
último año de esta preparatoria en
particular y es por eso que encuestamos
a una muestra de 100 alumnos así que
esta no es la respuesta correcta segunda
opción la población son todos los
estudiantes de esta preparatoria en
particular la muestra son todos los
estudiantes de último año de esta misma
preparatoria pues aquí claramente no
encuestaron a todos los estudiantes de
último año de esta preparatoria solo
encuestaron a 100 de ellos así que esta
tampoco es la respuesta correcta la
tercera opción dice la población no son
todos los estudiantes de último año de
esta preparatoria y si en efecto de esto
es de lo que estamos hablando aquí
queremos conocer la opinión sobre la
comida que se ofrece en la cafetería de
todos los estudiantes de último año de
esta preparatoria y quizás sea poco
práctico aplicar una encuesta a todos
los estudiantes de último año de esta
prepa y es por eso que mejor eligen una
muestra aleatoria de 100 estudiantes de
más
que la muestra son los 100 estudiantes
de último año que fueron encuestados